in 2019 over 35 million people across
Europe gave their votes to the
Socialists and Democrats Garcia Perez
was elected president of the s d group
once again the s d group was the leading
Progressive force in the European
Parliament from the start the s d
reinforced cooperation with our
commissioners with the PES and with our
national governments the challenges
quickly became clear the climate
emergency brexit and the rise of the far
right the covet pandemic Russia's war in
Ukraine and its social and economic
consequences all these crises happened
at the same time for personal and
political loss of our friend David
cersoli the late president of the
European Parliament
for progressives our values gave us a
signpost to guide us through these
crises by putting people at the center
the first fight was the green deal with
the red heart which we put to the center
of the commission's work plan this meant
a response to the climate emergency
based on social justice and solidarity
tools that ensure a fair transition to a
more sustainable Europe
this means the climate emergency
declaration 2019.
the social climate fund the fit for 55
package
the climate law
we turned our fight to make Europe
climate neutral by 2050 into real law
our work means that today's climate
commitments also protects the most
vulnerable in society
but there were other profound changes
happening in the European Union
the pandemic hits Europeans hard
especially the most fragile citizens
needed support Europe needed a recovery
plan so what did we do we pushed for an
historic 1.8 trillion Euros recovery
package we led the action plan on social
rights in the Porto Summit in 2021 we
supported the Next Generation EU
stimulus package
we made sure Europe's response was
investment rather than austerity
but other fights were still top of our
agenda a new European law and minimum
wages championed by the s d and adopted
in September 2022
a global minimum corporate tax rate
concrete improvements on the EU rules
against money laundering and
transparency thanks to the s d the
European Parliament established a
permanent subcommittee on tax policy
technological progress has impacted on
social progress with the digital
Services Act and the digital markets act
adopted in July 2022 the s d group
promoted a high level of consumer
protection
we also continue our fight for social
rights and fairness for platform workers
but being on the left we couldn't ignore
a number of civil rights battles the
pandemic came with a backlash on women's
rights we supported the commission's
proposal to fight gender-based violence
women's representation on corporate
boards finally this important directive
was approved closing gender pay Gap
currently under discussion between the
council and the European Parliament
the fight for gender equality remains
always at the core of our work
but the European values of democracy and
rule of law are also under attack
people's rights have been attacked by
right-wing EU governments women's right
to abortion
lgbtqi people's right to love who they
want so while the conservatives
supported the far-right we stood up
against bullies and autocrats in Hungary
Poland Slovenia and Bulgaria and made
sure EU taxpayers money would not fall
into corrupt hands
we also set up a special committee on
foreign interference to shine a light on
outside influence in our elections and
we successfully negotiated a new rule of
law conditionality mechanism in line
with our commitment to solidarity we
triggered the temporary protection
directive we want the same sense of
solidarity to apply to anyone seeking
protection in Europe
despite these immediate challenges we
always have one eye on the future we
supported the conference in the future
of Europe and many of the
recommendations from citizens like
creating a European health union
agreeing a social progress protocol
making Asylum and migration policy more
Humane protecting human rights and the
environment in business and trade
we wrote a new electoral law and hope
these Democratic changes are accepted by
the council
the future is also a digital world we
have put our stamp on Digital Services
and artificial intelligence with a fair
transparent and human-centered approach
we have also worked on future
Partnerships with like-minded
progressives from across the globe the
EU Africa partnership remains at the
heart of our external policy Itachi
Garcia LED missions to Latin America
Israel and Palestine strengthening ties
with sister parties
at home we are also working on concrete
policy recommendations that build a
better future for all through our work
in the Progressive Society initiative
our model of progressive trade and
business is protecting people and the
planet
we are leading on sustainable trade
deals and on new laws on responsible
business practices through mandatory due
diligence
[Music]
the war on Ukraine has serious
consequences for social cohesion and
economic stability in Europe without
support too many people risk having to
choose between Heating and eating this
winter
only a common European response with a
windfall tax and a cap on Energy prices
can give people the support they need
any challenge that we have to face we
always do it with the same values by
helping those in need and by standing
for solidarity Justice and equality
is
foreign